el gobierno británico estudia la
posibilidad de aumentar las
restricciones en todo el país dado que
en los últimos cinco días ha habido
contagios récords de más de 50.000
personas entretanto el primer ministro
boris johnson ha defendido no imponer
hasta el momento un tercer cierre
nacional un tercer confinamiento dado
que debe protegerse la economía y ha
defendido el sistema de restricciones
regionales se esperaba que las escuelas
abrieran después del receso de navidad
sus puertas este lunes pero en el caso
de la escuela secundaria estará cerrada
por varias semanas
boris johnson ha pedido a los padres que
enviaran los niños de la escuela
primaria para clases pese a que muchos
padres no creen que deba hacerse y
también algunas asociaciones de maestros
pero en el caso de londres éstas estarán
completamente cerradas en esta carrera
contra el coronavirus mañana también
iniciará la vacunación de oxford
astrazéneca una vacuna cuya logística es
mucho más sencilla los planes del
gobierno son que al menos dos millones
de personas
pueden ser vacunadas a la semana una
cifra muy ambiciosa pero lo que se
espera es que para abril por lo menos
los más vulnerables estén completamente
inmunizados contra el coronavirus